ethiopia has launched a military
offensive after rebel forces allegedly
attacked an army base
igniting fears of a civil war there are
reports that heavy fighting has broken
out in the northern state of tigre
where the government says local forces
attacked federal troops
in the city of michele trouble has been
brewing since the region held
elections last month in defiance of the
central government
prime minister avi ahmed who won the
nobel peace prize in 2019
said troops had been killed in a
televised address
he said the last red line had been
crossed
for 20 years the national defense force
has been in the bunkers defending this
country
by paying heavy sacrifices with its
blood and flesh
it's been attacked this evening in
mckelly and many other places by
traitors
and the forces they organized
for more on what's happening in ethiopia
i'm now joined by maria gatt nicolescu
our correspondent in addis ababa hello
maria there are reports of heavy
fighting in
tigre region what more can you tell us
so what we know so far is that the prime
minister accused
forces in the tigray region of attacking
federal military bases in order to steal
military equipment he said very early in
the morning that he had launched a
military operation in response to that
and he also said that the attack
carried out by the tigray region had
caused i quote many martyrs injuries
and property damage without giving exact
numbers and there are also rumors
of gunshots being heard by locals in the
tegradian capital
and mckele however is it is very
difficult
to get any information out of tigre at
the moment as
the internet and phone lines have been
completely shut off
now mr abbey has ordered the military
like you said to quote
carry out their mission to save their
country what exactly
does that mean abi ahmed said
in a statement today that war cannot be
prevented only on the goodwill and
decision of
one side and that he had used all means
to thwart a
military engagement basically what he's
saying is that the ruling party in the
tigray region
so basically his opposition party or one
of his opposition parties
has crossed a red line after months of
political tensions
and that he now has to intervene to
safeguard the country's stability
although many are saying that this is a
very dangerous move
now can you help us understand a bit
more here
what has led to the escalated situation
between tigray state
and the federal government
tensions have been growing between the
tigray people's liberation front or tplf
so basically the ruling party in the
tiguay region
and prime minister abi ahmed ever since
abi ahmed came to power in 2018. the
tegran party had
a huge political power for decades
before abi who is a from the oromia
region
was appointed prime minister so for the
past two years tigrayans had been
signed sidelined from the political
scene and its officials are feeling that
they are being
unfairly targeted and scapegoated for
the country's problems last year they
also refused to join abby's
new coalition party the prosperity party
and they opposed the government's
decision
to postpone elections due to the
coven-19 pandemic so this
has led these other tensions have led to
this escalation of which
we still um know little about okay
now uh briefly on this one how are
ordinary ethiopians reacting
to the increase in violence
as i said it's impossible to communicate
with anyone in tigre at the moment
and i would say people are mostly
worried worried because because they
cannot
talk to their relatives they're worried
about a possible armed conflict
they're asking themselves is there going
to be a civil war
um and yeah so we're seeing a lot of
people calling for authorities to work
towards de-escalation and conflict
resolution
maria get nicolescu dw correspondent in
ethiopia thank you for your time